today the world watched as Donald Trump
made good on his promise to move the US
Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem three
previous American presidents had
promised to do this
Jerusalem is still the capital of Israel
and must remain an undivided city
accessible at all as soon as I take
office I will begin the process of
moving the United States ambassador to
the city of Israel but when Trump
promised he actually delivered now
remember Congress passed a law
authorizing the embassy to move back in
1995 but every president has delayed it
until now Benjamin Netanyahu the Prime
Minister of Israel celebrated the
significance of the moment President
Trump became the first world leader to
recognize Jerusalem as our capital and
today the United States of America is
opening its embassy right here in
Jerusalem thank you thank you president
Trump for having the courage to keep
your promises it's a great day for
fantastic partnership but I believe it's
also a great day for peace now of course
if Israel is jubilant and Trump chalks
up another achievement well well well
the media reflexively wale and failed
politicians and diplomats of yesteryear
grouse it doesn't help to some extent it
hurts but mainly it just exposes again a
lack of a diplomatic strategy I hope
that the administration is seeing and
understands what the consequences are
gonna be if they do actually want to
restart the peace process
this decision was unboard and untethered
to any foreign policy consideration
peace process is comatose in the long
run it will not advance the peace
process it will make his own policy more
difficult to achieve and implement
that's the real issue
it greatly in flames and already very
turbulent violent region well as opposed
to what I mean George may so what you
negotiated I mean look if the old guard
the so-called wise man of diplomacy knew
so much such smart guys why are we still
struggling in 2018 to bring peace to the
region you had your shot and it didn't
work let's face it now it's Trump's turn
so what the critics failed to
acknowledge is that President Trump is
engaged in an international strategy
that is already paying some dividends
he's remaking alliances in the Middle
East and taking the old bargaining chips
off the table he's changing the old and
frankly the stale dynamic that was in
place Trump is reordering the status quo
and he's forcing our international
partners into new ways of thinking and
acting even if it seems uncomfortable
say what you want and a lot of you do
about the president's approach but he
has reinvigorated the prospects of peace
and places we never would have thought
change whatever happened and he's
created new possibilities a Huna fought
only a year ago that North Korea would
be willing to melt down its nuclear
testing facilities or even come to the
negotiating table no one thought that
except maybe president Trump himself at
home the economy is booming and the
president is demonstrating that bold
innovative leadership can get real
results abroad and at home now he's
appointing top-notch legal minds to the
federal bench we know that he's
untangling regulations that choke stifle
American businesses large and small and
now he's even tackling prescription drug
prices he did that last week and he's
gonna be working on that so even as the
media are loath to cover any of this at
least fairly the public I think gets it
so Trump's numbers are climbing but the
only group of course that hasn't gotten
the memo is the resistance media and
their pals and politics they consist
we ignore the president's achievements
while grasping at any straw to assail
him well today's straw was a side
comment made last week by a White House
aide during a private meeting about
ailing Senator John McCain a White House
aide mocks them and they interject that
they stand with the person mocking John
McCain for having brain cancer they
don't believe in apologies and it's easy
to assume that the President of the
United States was okay with this being
said she had still not publicly
apologized and she is still an employee
here at the White House this shows
something about the culture of the Trump
White House that has nothing to do with
politics liberal conservative Republican
or Democrat that there has been a kind
of indecency that's been permitted I'm
sorry
I had to be awakened from them into
montage come on this staffer called
McCain's family and personally
apologized of course they want a public
apology for what was a private leaked
comment and I was thinking about this
afternoon can you imagine what team
Obama said about Trump and his staff his
team or any of his supporters behind
closed doors I shudder to think what
they said come on you know what this is
really all about trying to revive the
president's comments about McCain made
during the campaign about the being a
powa which were unfortunate comments but
to do that in an effort to somehow hurt
Trump now now it didn't work then and I
don't think it will work now while the
media and their friends and politics
obsess about thoughtless comments and
non essentials
few members of the media seem interested
in doing their actual jobs pursuing the
stories that actually touch and affect
our lives what about holding our
institutions accountable accountable to
the people to pay the bills why are the
media so in curious about the FBI's
investigation of Hillary Clinton and
commis decision not to indict her what
about
the reports of partisanship in the FBI
possible corruption within the mother
probe wars are reporting on divin
newness attempts to get the Justice
Department to hand over documents
explaining how the FBI's Russian
collusion probe started and who actually
started it I mean new Nets had to
threaten rod Rosa Steen with impeachment
basically to get a response and he still
hasn't seen all the documents in
question now isn't that worth
investigating
put Trump aside or what you think about
Trump aside the Justice Department and
the FBI stonewalling those with actual
oversight responsibilities or have porn
stars and Russian collusion conspiracy
theories saft all the media's manpower
in all of their energy and resources if
the press think about this spent just a
little bit of time covering some of
those stories well maybe more Americans
might listen when they reported
critically on the president but so long
as the press is just a wing of the
resistance their audience will scatter
it'll dwindle and soon most of America
will just tune them out so I say go
ahead and cover criticism of the
president but once in a while just try
balancing out with some honest coverage
of some of the groundbreaking successes
and the real achievements we all need
the press to hold everyone accountable
Trump surely but also the other sectors
of government as well including the FBI
and that's the angle